that's a great blues note and suddenly
as soon as you add that in
there you're in the world of the
[Music]
Blues in my last video Samurai guitar
gave me my first ever Blues lesson we
covered an intro to the 12 Bar Blues we
talked about soloing using the
pentatonic scale and more so watch that
video If you haven't but in this video
we're going to go even deeper and talk
about the famous Blue Notes as well as
more complicated and in-depth soloing
ideas here we go
[Music]
so we take that pentatonic scale but we
can play other notes with that and I
think when you start the bles not yeah
it's it is the blues note so the Blue
Note would be the third fret of the uh
of the G so that's a B
[Music]
flat okay and that note is like
distinctly not in yeah that's a flat
five of the uh of the E of e and so the
flat five sharp four is
like cool that one sounds very very bluy
sure with that note I'm never just going
to sit on that cuz it's pretty harsh
okay again with this I wouldn't do it
but maybe you would do it and that's the
beauty of this is if it sounds good to
you go for it there's no rules here
these are just kind of guidelines and
expectations so if you want to just sit
on that as you play the
E7 I wouldn't do that but that doesn't
mean you can't but I mean do you think
about it it's a it's a passing you pass
through it from a coming to B yeah it's
a passing tone or if I were to
intellectualize it I'm thinking we're
just going to like touch that every now
and then to give it a flavor but we're
never going to sit on that and highlight
it okay that's how I would
intellectualize it but the goal with
this music is that you're never thinking
about it and that's when the best stuff
happens is when you essentially turn off
the thinking part of your brain and you
just let it flow out of you as if it's
like a flow State um you got to put the
work in to get to that point where you
never have to think anymore and it's
just you turn your brain off and it just
happens automatically right but that's
the ultimate goal and when I talk about
these things about like playing A7 or
any of that like you don't want to you
want to thought so much about it you
don't need to think about it so when you
say how do I think about it I don't
really I just kind of I'm imagining a
Melody at the same time I'm I'm playing
it it happens so with that note that's a
great blues note and suddenly as soon as
you add that in
there you're in the world of the
[Music]
Blues today's video is brought to you by
classical guitar Pro that's my brand new
online classical guitar course which is
6 hours 53 videos it's a whole
curriculum designed to teach you what
you would normally learn in the first 6
months to a year of classical guar
lessons so if you want to learn
classical guar but are stuck struggling
reading music or struggling to learn the
techniques check out classical
guitarpro to learn more so why don't we
play another Blues progression and I'm
going to let you add that note in there
and see what you think of that one okay
one 2 3
[Music]
4 there we
go
I got to pass
[Music]
through I'm not happy with this at all
it's hard to use it I have I feel like
I'm trying to use it the right moments
but I'm not getting the the tasteful
result you got let's let me play through
this once and I'm going to try to keep
playing within those uh limitations that
we've set up so far okay one 2 3
[Music]
four
yeah so you so you like this one and
then you go you yeah so I guess I'm kind
of venturing out of that first littleit
of the pentatonic scale I can't I can't
help it I don't know it's like it's kind
of just an instinctual thing where you
you've played enough blue Sol I totally
get what you're saying I I I love all of
this and it's a little bit like you were
saying in the classical atre lesson it's
like you learn all this good stuff and
you really I just really want to go
practice for a while and come back to to
like lock it all in because I see what
you're doing and I think I think I get
the gist of it but it's hard to do it
instantly you need like the the hours of
jamming uh to kind of like make it uh to
do it without thinking as you were
saying and right now I'm so I'm
calculating everything I it's kind of
like spoiling the the raw well that's
the nature of that's truly what the
nature of the Blues is too it's like
it's an interaction in real time that
you're just expressing whatever this is
within you and the same way like when
you're doing classical stuff you're
taking your notes that are pre-planned
and then the emotion that you put into
them is in the moment but with the blues
it's you're kind of more focused on the
notes are the the thing that you're
bringing in there that you've never
played before yeah in that specific
combination and and when it Just Hits
just right like when you play something
you're like wow that sounded great it's
like such a great feeling and it's okay
if you hit a wrong note half the time
you hit a wrong note just hit it again
people are going to think you're doing
it on purpose right who said that to
some like whether you whether or not
that was whether or not that was a right
note depends on the next note you play
makes a lot of sense in this type of
style I think less than classical yeah
there are no such things as wrong notes
I don't think there's always a way that
you can tie a note in and you can use
them is like passing tones leading to
other things so why don't we go one
little step further and I think that
will be far enough with our our our
blues guitar lesson okay um so the one
other thing that I think makes such a
huge difference is each one of these
chords so far we've been thinking of
this blue
scale as a blanket scale we're just
going to pick notes throw them over top
of these chords right but each chord
those are three different chords they
similarities and a relationship they all
have but I'll treat each of these chords
a little bit different front line that
was my next question for you because my
the first thing I encountered when we
were jamming is that I was I was
thinking about what chord to be playing
now what am I harmonizing over because
if you're not aware of the chord changes
you can play some you know not ideal
dissonances I so do you when do you
think I'm now in the four chords so now
these combinations work I'm now in the
one chord so these combinations work um
if I were to really break it down there
is for sure an element of that at play
but again it's more of an instinctual
thing at this point the way that I will
think is like so over the E over the one
chord I'm thinking that the flat third
the G is going to sound good but also
the natural third so the G sharp is
going to sound good yeah so if I'm
playing over that one chord I'm going to
try to highlight it by doing
[Music]
like and so I keep on kind of focusing
on that I'm bringing in that major third
a
lot nice so I'm hitting that I'm kind of
seeking that note out a bunch and if you
want to take it one step further you
have the B7 B7 is an interesting chord
because there's a lot of ways you can
approach the ways that you play over top
of the B7 so you could like the
difference here the new note that you're
introducing here would be the uh the D
sharp Y and so sometimes like you'll
want to if you really want to accentuate
your B7 you're
you're hitting that that that D sharp
lead the tone to the e but yeah because
that's the uh what's that that's the
third the natural third of the B7 yeah
also the leading tone that pulls you
back to to e yeah so that's a great
thing to put in there but also you could
be thinking of this as a B7 with a sharp
nine W and so you can actually play put
that note in there too the D
natural against the D sh yeah like
oh so that's like a thing I could play
from the turn around why don't you just
do just a turn around I'll try to show
you how I might bring that in there oh
one 2 3
[Music]
4 and so did you hear like now I'm
outlining each of those chords with that
Melody I'm playing one of the things
that is kind of boggling my mind right
now is I am trying to quantify the
harmony of each chord and then like what
are the dis intervals you're adding
because when I when I improvise in
figured base which is the Baro style of
improvisation you just you read off of a
baseline And there are there are numbers
with what works in the chord and there
are dissonances that are allowed in
those Styles but these dissonances are
so hard to predict I mean going okay I'm
okay we're in E Major I just think
you're you're thinking too much and I
naturally I like to think about an
intellectualize as well but that's not
the nature like you think of where this
music came from it came from essentially
yeah folk people there was a lot of
illiteracy a lot of poverty there they
weren't writing this down and trying to
figure it out sure there's some of that
in there but that's not the the heart of
this music it's just you're expressing a
thing that you've heard a million times
and you don't know why and that's a hard
thing I think it it's been a hard thing
for me to get away from because I really
like to figure it out and learn why is
hard to yeah the analysis it sounded
good so I did it that's it and that
comes from just hours and hours of
learning it yeah and I think if you were
to go further down this this Blues world
the thing that I would recommend right
away is to set some of those things
aside that you want to control and
understand and purely figure it out from
the ear first cool and then down the
line you might say okay well now I want
to think about why that works you're
like oh okay now I understand it yeah
but really I learned it first and
foremost through the feel and through
the ear and I think that's that's the
way to do it you know what this reminds
me of it reminds me of in in uh Spanish
book music and like flamco music which
you know it comes from gypsies in like
Spain who like like you know they they
weren't uh people approaching this music
from an analytical point of view they
were jamming on guitars exactly you get
this very guitaristic chord E major and
then at some point somebody you know
surely accidentally went here and this
is the same shape and it sounds
fantastic and in in my Master's I
remember analyzing some type of like um
pseudo flamco kind of Spanish uh
classical tar piece and they use this
score all the time and to theoretically
analyze this chord you have to it's like
a polytonal chord with F major
Tendencies with E and then and
analytically it's just like so
convoluted but really what is it it's a
happy accident yeah yeah it's a happy
accident and it sounded good so they did
it some more yeah and I think that's
that's the root of a lot of blue stuff
is it sounds good so I'm going to do
that a bit
more well so it's one of those things
where that might be a a motif that often
recurs so all these little motifs are
like built into your muscle memory in a
way that is so evident because you're
not I can see what you're saying you're
not thinking it just comes out of your
fingers so naturally one of the first
things we did in our classical lesson
was we I had to think about my element
of touch which was like completely
different really fun but with the blues
it just it kind of develops naturally
and you do things
like like these little scrapes
[Music]
that's and like these little techniques
that I don't even know what the name is
for these but they just you hear them
and so so much the sound as well like
your tamber is like you're using like
something like snaps like sometimes this
the tone like yeah it's like a Snappy
tone that in the if I'm thinking like a
classical guitarist we don't ever want
this type of like Snappy sound we this
we never use that it's always pure
sounds it doesn't sound as good on a
classical guitar I would say but when
you put that on electric which is where
a lot of Blues is played or a steel
string there is a gentle side of it but
a lot of the time you're expressing like
raw human emotions and you're hitting
things hard and I think that would be
like cuz pain the blues are it's about
pain yeah it's a music of suffering is
where it comes from and yeah there's a
gentle side of that like you hear guys
going
[Music]
like but it's like also there's that
toughness within there that uh whatever
that is that it's not quite as gentle as
like a the way that a classical
guitarist might play that stuff I love
it and so I would say like that's an
introductory lesson to the blues and I
hope you enjoyed it this was great I
mean you you expanded my mind here a lot
and I I love the concept of kind of like
turning off the analytical side and just
feeling it through hours and hours of
experience so this is great man thank
you yeah thanks for having me it's been
a treat all right well I hope you guys
enjoyed if you're not already subscribe
please subscribe to Samurai guitarist I
love his videos uh and I hope you check
them out so thank you thank you till
next time see
you
[Music]